S
CNN THE SECOND ROUND OF TALKS
BETWEEN UKRAINE AND RUSSIA WILL
TAKE PLACE TODAY IN BELARUS.
WHAT WILL COME OF THAT REMAINS
TO BE SEEN.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR JOINING US.
CHRISTIANE, YOU SPOKE WITH
UKRAINE'S FOREIGN MINISTER
YESTERDAY.
WHAT DID HE TELL YOU?
WHERE IS HE AT IN THIS MOMENT?
>> WE DESCRIBED A BUNKER IN AN
UNDISCLOSED LOCATION, BUT
NONETHELESS IN KYIV IN UKRAINE
TO TALK ABOUT HOW HE SAW THIS
PLAYING OUT.
AS THE INCREASED TARGETING OF
CIVILIANS WAS TAKING PLACE.
WHAT HE SAID WAS ACTUALLY VERY
INTERESTING, BECAUSE HE SAID HE
HAD SPOKEN TO THE CHINESE
FOREIGN MINISTER, HIS
COUNTERPART, AND THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE CHINESE,
YOU REMEMBER THE FAMOUS PICTURES
OF THE BEGINNING OF THE OLYMPICS
WHEN PRESIDENT XI AND PUTIN
BASICALLY DECLARED A NO HOLDS
BARRED, ANYTHING GOES
FRIENDSHIP.
WELL, NOW THE CHINESE HAVE
ACTUALLY SWITCHED SINCE THIS
INVASION AND SINCE THE TARGETING
OF CIVILIANS AND HAVE EVEN
MENTIONED CIVILIANS IN THEIR
WORRY ABOUT CIVILIANS AND HAVE
CALLED ON -- THAT'S A BIG
CONCERN, AND THEY HAVE OFFERED
TO HELP IN ANY KIND OF
DEESCALATION.
THIS IS WHAT THE UKRANIAN
FOREIGN MINISTER TOLD ME.
>> HE ASSURED ME THAT CHINA IS
NOT INTERESTED IN THIS WAR AND
IS READY TO SEEK PEACEFUL
SOLUTION OF THIS CONFLICT
THROUGH DIPLOMACY.
SO I APPEALED TO THE CHINESE
FOREIGN MINISTER AND ALSO TO THE
INDIA FOREIGN MINISTER TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THEIR LEVERAGE ON
PUTIN, OF THEIR RELATIONSHIP
WITH RUSSIA, AND URGE PUTIN TO
STOP THIS WAR IMMEDIATELY.
>> SO, AGAIN, VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE CHINA OBVIOUSLY HAS A
HUGE LEVERAGE AND HUGE INTRICATE
RELATIONSHIP WITH PUTIN HIMSELF.
SO DOES INDIA.
SO DOES WILLIAM COHEN, THE
FORMER U.S. SECRETARY, SAID
INDIA COULD PLAY AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN THIS AS WELL.
IN OTHER WORDS, GET THE
COUNTRIES WHO MAY STILL HAVE
SOME KIND OF IN OR INFLUENCE
WITH PUTIN TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
KULEBA IS ALSO CALLING ON THE
U.N. TO STRIP RUSSIA